how much are you following what's going
on with genan editing with this company
called crisper that just got this new
approval by the FD on December 8 2023
crisper Gene editing drug for sickle
cell disease has officially been
approved so imagine what this whole Gene
editing means let's just say you know
how nowadays people say I don't want to
just have one baby I just want to do it
once and I want to have three babies you
couldn't do that before that's normal
now what if you can go to the doctor and
you say Okay doc here's the menu what
would you like I want them to be 65 no
no babe that's too tall 63 and A2 he's
going to be 63 and A2 what color eyes
you want him to have green eyes green
eyes it is how big arms do you want you
have what how about shoe size I'd like
him to end up having 13 and a half oh
that's exactly what he's going how about
hair blonde no not blonde let can you
imagine if you could do that the way
that's the direction we're going this
company crisper gets started in 2013
goes public in 2016 becomes almost a
$200 share company right now it's around
60 to $68 give or take $4.5 billion
company and while you're listening to
this and you're saying Pat this is
craziness there's no way we're going
this direction well apparently crisper
can cure cancer blood disorders
blindness AIDS cystic fibrosis muscular
distrophy Huntington disease and
covid-19 and by the way you want to know
a little weird thing what's going on
with China in 2020 a US intelligence
report showed that China conducted human
testing on members of The People's
Liberation Army pla in Hope of
developing Soldiers with biologically in
capabilities similar to movies like
Captain America bloodshot and universal
Soldier that's the direction we're going
to today this simple patent that was
started by somebody in UC Berkeley this
lady who starts it but the credit to the
patent ends up going to Harvard and MIT
and they're the ones that own this
concept called crisper so we're going to
talk about that today very weird stick
[Music]
around
if you get value out of this video give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel let's get right into it again
crisper what is it even stand for
clustered regularly interspaced short
palindromic repeats is what crisper
stands for now according to statista the
market size for this in 2023 is $2.4
billion but in 10 years they're
predicting for it to be shy of $33
billion this is a revolutionary
technology in the field of genetics it's
a tool that allows scientists to
precisely edit genes with organisms
crisper is used to make specific changes
in the DNA of plants animals and humans
this includes adding removing or
altering sections of the DNA sequence
the reason why I have a smile on my face
is because you're pretty much playing
God is what you're doing what kind of a
human being do you want to build what
kind of an animal do you want what kind
of a plant do you want they can even fix
your salad the flavor The Taste they can
make a carrot taste like cherries they
can do all this this is not just like
out of a movie this is actually reality
what we're going to right now so crisper
cast 9 edits Jeans by precisely cutting
DNA and then harnessing natural DNA
repair processes to modify the gene in
the desired manner the system has two
components the cast 9 enzyme and a guide
RNA now here's what's important I mean
this company got started 2013 goes
public 2016 is worth around $4.5 billion
their CEO is somebody that's been at
McKenzie for 9 years smart Karne so
that's somebody that's connected when
you're with McKenzie you know you have
connections with everybody so imagine
the contact of hey we're trying to get
this product into this McKenzie
relationship countries foreign other
companies Investments it's the right
lineage of opportunities for this
company and they already as of 2023 more
than 200 people have have been treated
with experimental crisper therapies I'll
give you a couple testimonies and
stories here first one is Victoria gr
37-year-old Survivor of CLE cell disease
spoke about her transformative
experience with genetic treatment she
described a childhood and Adolescence
marked by severe symptoms and Dreams
Deferred after receiving a transfusion
of genetically edited cells from her
bone marrow which she call supercells
she felt an immediate sense of rebirth
and gradually saw significant Health
Improv movements over 7 to 8 months her
story marked by Newfound enjoyment of
Life deeply moved the audience including
typically stoic scientist what's
important to know is some of may be
watching so is this stem cells is that
what you're talking because everybody's
talking about stem cells stem cell is
something you add either you can take it
from your own body and give it back to
yourself or you can take it from
somebody else and put it in yourself
this is they're taking a part of your
Gene out they're editing it putting a
new one in there to manipulate it in
other words and that's what they did
with Victoria G here's another one
October 2021 chrisper Therapeutics gave
preliminary results for individuals with
lymphomas who had been treated and
followed for at least for 4 weeks after
treatment side effects were not severe
and the safety profile was Superior to
other CRT products in these patients
almost 60% showed a positive response to
treatments with 21% showing no signs of
disease for 6 months after a single
treatment that leaves 19% does that me
the other 19% turn into zombies they
didn't tell us what happened to the
other 19% but apparently 60% showed
positive response so you got to keep
this in mind
21% shown no signs of disease after 6
months after a single treatment that's
one in five no longer have cancer what
how many people you think would want to
say I want to be part of that 200 but
again not enough research that's what's
only 200 them but let's continue 2017
team of researchers led by shukar
mitalipov a genetic uh at Oregon Health
and Science University in Portland
reported that human embryos carrying a
mutation could be repaired using this
method the researchers generate embryos
from a union between two cells a sperm
carrying a mutation that can make it
harder for the heart to pump blood and
an egg with a healthy version of the
gene doctor and his team used crisper
cast 9 to cut the broken copy of the
gene to see if the intact version would
guide its repair they reported the
experiment a success and published it in
the journal Nature this is pretty wild
if you think about what it's saying you
go to the doctor the doctor tells you
your baby has a 70% chance of being down
syndrome these guys can use crisper cast
9 to cut the Gene and edit it with the
right Gene so the kid will be okay won't
end up being down syndrome so this is
personal to me because we've gone
through it in our family think about the
possibilities of what this could do
again you are playing God but the
capabilities are unbelievable here's
another one for you at verse results
27-year-old Terry Horan was
participating in a clinical trial for a
crisper treatment aimed at duen muscular
distrophy tragically passed away duen
muscular distrophy is a fatal condition
characterized by progressive muscle
degeneration the exact cause of Terry's
death and whether it was related to the
crisper treatment remains unclear by the
way the other negative adverse results
of this could be a the wrong
Arrangements of DNA so imagine they're
rearranging the DNA and all of a sudden
the sequencing is off which could lead
to random mutations by error you don't
know what that's going to look like
there's obviously big risk for that so
maybe a person that's willing to use
this is on the last straw and they're
saying look I'm willing to be tested for
this because the alternative is I'm dead
I'll test this out yes but there's also
adverse risk to what's possible because
they're barely learning about this stuff
here's another crazy story for you this
one brace for impact cuz it's a little
too crazy so fetal gene therapy in 2018
when he Janu a Chinese scientists use
the technology to yield the world's
first Gene edited infants but it doesn't
end there the experiment was widely
condemned as irresponsible and dangerous
in large part because many of the ways
in which crisper cast 9 can affect cells
remain poorly understood the doctor was
found guilty of conducting illegal
medical practices in China and was
sentenced to 3 years in prison
apparently he said these infants are
built in a perfect way where they'll
never have AIDS how are you going to
know if they're never going to have AIDS
this the part where the this technology
in the wrong people's hands what are
they going to do with it and can you
imagine well no we're just going to do
all good there's a lot of weird people
in the world those scientists that sit
in the lab and they're like I'm going to
test all this stuff out what are they
going to be building that's another one
of those things that concern certain
people so so here's the thing there's a
couple ways you can think about this
none of this should surprise any one of
us if you saw fly the movie that's Gene
editing if you saw X-Men the movie
that's Gan editing they were capable of
doing some crazy stuff you think that's
just the movie movie like one day
somebody won't be able to do that if you
saw Jurassic Park Gene editing alysium
Gene editing Star Trek G I can give you
a lot of different movies you know these
movies Gene editing it's not abnormal
that this is taking place and people are
inspired a lot of these movies are
predictive programming that one day
someone's going to be doing this the
question then becomes is the following
you saw the movie Oppenheimer and you're
sitting you're like okay we invented
something that can destroy the world
just so you know we have it today if you
and I wanted to destroy the world today
the world has it today it's not like we
have had it we've had it for a long time
how come the world hasn't been destroyed
well so far somebody evil hasn't yet
pressed the button does that mean
someone's not going to do in the future
of course not it just means we haven't
yet does it mean somebody can take this
and grow it to a level where we lose
control of it well that's the problem
with AI right what if you keep building
Ai and the battle between Elon and some
of these other folks the humanists and
the guys that are thinking we ought to
build AI what if robots become stronger
than us what if this Gene editing
creates a gene where it's so powerful
that you lose control of it what do we
have to do capture it arrest it all
these thoughts that you think about
right where it can go it's endless
stories um however it is concerning
there's a lot of good that can be done
with it when guns were invented
everybody thought it was it it was
terrible it protected others from
bullying others bullies were now afraid
to go break into a house the good the
bad the ugliest they're here with this
uh but this the closest thing to us
playing God if we go in this direction
and if there's a God I don't know if
God's going to be happy about this if
we're not sitting there you know saying
hey this is good what you've done so far
but we going to take it to a whole
different level because we got something
you never know how to do if there is a
guy who's going to say okay relax here's
what I'm going to do boom go restart
what yes again if there isn't we'll see
that as well there's a lot of this that
can be deeply concerning with what
direction it goes to I think it's just
the beginning but if you think this is
not going to be happening or it's not
going to be around you're also naive and
you're fooling yourself having said that
if you got value out of this video give
a thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
I did a video on China's demographics of
if you never seen this so imagine if
China uses Gene editing to increase the
number of girls or boys that they want
to have with their population to catch
up who knows if you've never seen it
click here to watch the video take care
everybody bye-bye
bye-bye